-The Supreme Court issued
a historic ruling
on LGBTQ civil rights
as officials across the country
move toward police reform.
Meanwhile,
the president is defending
the way he walked down a ramp.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Let's just get this
out of the way first.
The president, as we all know,
is a weird man --
deeply weird.
And on Saturday, he once again
showed off
his fundamental weirdness
after a speech at West Point
when he slowly descended
a ramp like an old man
being walked across the street
by a boy scout.
You know, for a guy
who constantly
talks about how tough he is,
he sure walks like a baby deer
on a frozen pond.
What is wrong with him?
Are we going to have to get him
an Acorn stairlift?
[ As Trump ] Acorn One.
[ Normal voice ] I watched that,
and for the first time
thought [bleep]
maybe he does have bone spurs.
Naturally, this prompted
a lot of speculation
about the president's health.
Have his bones been hollowed out
by years of artificial sweetener
and asbestos?
Is his blood mostly ketchup
and Diet Coke?
Still, we,
we are not going to speculate.
But if Donald Trump saw
someone else walking like that,
you know he would definitely
speculate.
He'd be on Twitter all day
saying things like,
"An extremely credible source
tells me the president
has hamburger leg.
Must investigate!"
And, yet, Trump couldn't help
but spend time responding
to the speculation on Twitter
with a truly ludicrous
explanation.
-The president tweeted,
"The ramp that I descended
after my West Point commencement
speech was very long and steep,
had no handrail,
and most importantly,
was very slippery.
The last thing I was going to do
is 'fall' for the fake news
to have fun with.
Final ten feet I ran
down to level ground.
Momentum!"
-Wow. So liberals, young people,
and women hate you,
and now we have to add
ramp designers to the list.
Okay.
So let me get this straight.
The ramp was long, steep,
and slippery.
It was a Slip 'N Slide.
You're saying the West Point
ramp was a Slip 'N Slide.
[ As Trump ] It was
a very treacherous ramp
coated with oil,
littered with banana peels.
And due to a luggage mix-up,
the only footwear available
to me were a pair of Heelys.
Heelys. You've got to be careful
on your Heelys.
[ Normal voice ] So that's
what the president
chose to spend his time
focusing on this weekend.
Now, generally speaking,
good news has been
hard to come by these days.
So when the Republican-dominated
Supreme Court
handed down a landmark decision
this morning
on whether
federal civil rights law
prohibits discrimination
against LGBTQ people,
I was ready for disappointment.
Then this happened.
-A major civil rights decision
out of the United States
Supreme Court.
The Supreme Court has ruled
that LGBT Americans
are protected
by the anti-discrimination laws
of this country
at their workplaces.
This is a major civil rights
opinion in the Supreme Court.
It was written by Justice
Neil Gorsuch
and joined
by Chief Justice John Roberts.
-The decision now is clear
from the Supreme Court.
They have issued a ruling
that now bans discrimination
by employers
against transgender individuals
and gay individuals.
This is a key, a landmark ruling
for gay and transgender
individuals.
It was actually authored
by conservative justice
Neil Gorsuch.
He was joined
by the Chief Justice,
John Roberts, as well as
the liberal justices here.
It is a massive victory for
transgender and gay individuals.
-What?!
Something good happened?!
This is -- This is incredible!
Break out the champagne!
What?
Oh, we don't have any champagne?
What about wine?
We drank all the wine?
Is there anything,
anything we could --
That's it? That's literally
the only thing we have?
Okay.
Break out the canned tuna,
everybody,
because it's time to celebrate!
That's right.
The Supreme Court ruled
that federal civil rights law
forbids discrimination against
gay and transgender Americans.
It's incredible news.
And it's especially great
because the one thing
Trump could say,
he had delivered
for his extremist base
was the Supreme Court.
And now even the Supreme Court
is bucking him.
When Trump heard the news,
he probably needed
a glass of water,
if only he could get it
up to his mouth.
Dude, what's up?
This is like watching
one of those improv games
where a performer puts
their arms through some else's.
This whole time, has it been
President Trump and Ryan Stiles?
Ryan Stiles! Attic reference!
Can't do that in the studio.
Can someone just get Trump
a really long straw
so we never have to see this
again?
So, this was a thrilling
and momentous ruling
and comes just days after
the Trump administration
announced that it was
rolling back Obama-era
civil right protections
for transgender Americans
in healthcare.
Because any time
Trump has an opportunity
to be an [bleep] he takes it.
I'd say the Trump presidency
is like a slippery slope
toward authoritarianism,
but given how bad he is at it,
it's more like a slippery ramp.
Not the last ramp reference,
by the way.
I'd love to tell you it was,
but we are going to circle back
and call it back one more time.
Do you want to try
and see it coming?
Maybe you can see it coming.
So, there was good news today
on LGBTQ civil rights.
And at the same time, we're also
seeing a flurry of legislation
and a massive shift in public
opinion on systemic racism
and police brutality
amid the historic
Black Lives Matter protests
sweeping the nation.
Thanks to the unprecedented
outpouring
of public pressure in the form
of mass demonstrations,
officials across the country
have been moving toward
police reform in ways
big and small.
The Minneapolis City Council
passed a resolution
to disband the police
and invest in community-based
public safety programs.
The governor of Iowa signed
a police reform bill
that was passed in one day.
The Louisville Metro Council
banned no-knock warrants.
New York State repealed the law
that kept police brutality
records secret.
Confederate statues across
the country have been toppled.
And cities and states are
barring police
from using choke holds
and tear gas.
Now, there's
a wide spectrum there.
Some of the these moves
are good first steps,
others are clearly insufficient.
But I have to
say, in the year 2020,
banning choke holds
and taking down monuments
to white supremacy should be
the absolute bare minimum.
We shouldn't be satisfied
with that.
It's like going in for a checkup
and your doctor saying,
"Just so you know,
I graduated high school."
People have been pouring into
the streets for weeks,
demanding far-reaching changes
and a fundamental rethinking
of how much policing we really
need, and what, if anything,
we need policing for,
which is why
the "de-fund police" movement
has gained steam.
In New York City, for example,
the city council has proposed
a plan that would cut $1 billion
from the NYPD budget
that could be put to use
elsewhere, like in housing,
healthcare, homeless and mental
health services,
or de-lousing
the Times Square Elmo.
We might need another billion.
Or how about we spend that money
on a study to find out
what the hell those liquid
nitrogen tanks
are doing on the street corners
in Manhattan?
I mean, I've lived in this city
for two decades.
I have no idea, no idea
what those things are for.
They look like a bonus item
you'd unlock
in "Grand Theft Auto."
The more people hear about
the reality of policing
in this country, the more
they agree that small reforms
at the margins are not enough.
We need to de-fund and scale
back policing altogether.
For example, here's an insane
headline from 2014
that resurfaced recently.
"L.A. schools police
will return grenade launchers
but keep rifles,
armored vehicle."
Oh, good, I'm glad they returned
the grenade launchers.
Also, why the [bleep] did they
have grenade launchers?
Were they providing backup
to the hall monitors?
"We have a student roaming the
hall with no bathroom pass!
I repeat, no bathroom pass!"
Throughout this crisis,
Americans have witnessed
police abuse their authority
with impunity,
and sometimes in the most absurd
and inexplicable ways,
as Illinois Congressman
Bobby Rush discovered recently.
-Last week, the Congressman
got word that his office
in Chicago had been burglarized.
But when he went to look
at the surveillance tape,
this is what he found --
A group of up to 13
police officers
helping themselves to coffee,
making popcorn,
even napping in his office,
while outside stores were being
damaged and robbed.
-That's right.
Police officers broke into
a congressman's office to make
coffee and popcorn
and take naps without checking
for cameras first!
Did you think bulletproof vests
make you invisible?
"I don't know what happened,
Sarge.
I was wearing the vest."
They treated a congressman's
office
the way George Costanza
treated his desk.
And then there's this truly
insane story from Ohio,
where police tried to claim
protesters were showing up
to demonstrations with weapons
until the truth came out.
Columbus Police posted about
a protest bus
being equipped with riot gear --
clubs, rocks, axes, et cetera.
It turns out the bus belonged
to "hippie circus" performers.
The clubs were juggling clubs.
The rocks were crystals
and fossils.
On the long list
of most threatening people,
the very bottom entry
is "people who travel
with crystals and fossils."
If you're walking down
a dark alley
and you run into a guy
with a crystal,
the only thing you're at risk of
is a slightly longer
conversation about crystals
than you probably want to have.
The only other thing worse
than considering that a threat
would be issuing a warning
that a receiving gang of thugs
is catching people's dreams.
"If you hear wind chimes, run!"
I mean, what else do they do,
pull over a clown car
and conduct a search?
"All right, everybody,
step out of the car.
Yes, you too, sir,
and you and you.
And that's got to be everybody.
Okay, you too?
And you and you and you --
I'm going to need some backup.
We got, yeah,
more than you think."
So, people have witnessed
firsthand brutality
and abuses of power
by the police.
And in response,
they're pouring into the streets
for mass demonstrations
across the country.
It's an unprecedented movement
that has galvanized
and swayed public opinion,
in which the president still
clearly does not understand.
-What do you think
the protesters --
Not the looters and the rioters.
We're intelligent enough
to know the difference
in our country, right?
-Sure.
What do you think they want?
What do you think they need
right now from you?
-So I think you had protesters
for different reasons.
And then you had protesting
also because, you know,
they just didn't know.
I've watched.
I watched it very closely.
Why are you here?
And they really weren't able
to say,
but they were there
for a reason, perhaps.
But a lot of them
really were there
because they're following
the crowd.
-What is wrong with you?
You think the protesters
were there
just because they were following
the crowd?
First of all,
this is the age of corona.
I know you forgot,
but it still is.
Nobody's following a crowd
without having
a very good reason.
"You guys gonna walk close
together and chant?
And, hey, that's
all I need to know."
Also, what do you mean
some of them were there
for a reason, perhaps?
He's so addled, he can't
even say what the reason is.
He answers questions
about systemic racism
and police brutality
with all the specificity
of a mobster who knows his phone
is being tapped.
"I'll meet you down at the place
to talk about the thing,
you know, for a reason."
Or maybe Trump
was just distracted
because he knew he had to
go down a ramp in two days.
[ As Trump ] I'm sorry,
what was the question?
I was just trying to game
something out in my head.
We're going to do a careful
step, careful step.
Okay, maybe a couple
real fast ones.
Yeah, yeah, no, I think --
I think that will look cool
and people will think that was
a cool thing that I did.
[ Normal voice ] Now,
as we have said before,
thanks to organizers
and activists
doing the work on the ground,
in the streets,
we have seen a massive shift
in public opinion in favor
of the Black Lives Matter
movement
just in a very short period
of time.
-Public opinion
appears to be moving rapidly
in the direction
of the protesters.
Just look at this graph from
"The New York Times"' "Upshot."
In the past two weeks, support
for Black Lives Matter increased
by nearly as much as it had
over the previous two years.
-It was like lightning striking
when you feel that electricity
building up in a storm.
-It's true. What we've seen
is a lightning strike.
And Trump has clearly been
struck. I mean, look at him.
This is why they tell you
to get off the golf course
when you hear thunder.
"Mr. President, what happened?"
[ As Trump ] I don't know,
I was about to play
a knock-down six iron
into the green,
and the next thing I remember is
waking up in the urgent care.
Today we saw a historic victory
for LGBTQ civil rights,
and we're watching
an unprecedented sea change
in public opinion on systemic
racism in police brutality,
and the president has decided
he'd rather spend his time
whining about the media coverage
of the way he walked down
a ramp.
But, clearly,
in the eyes of history,
Trump is the one slipping,
while the people fighting
for justice
are the ones who have the...
-"Momentum!"
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
As New York struggles to reopen,
remember that we're still
a city in crisis,
and City Harvest
has been stepping up
to meet the increased need.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
we love you.